all right choice yes sir troy so where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i grew up in compton
grew up in uh i was born in 1963.
my mom
my dad
my dad was a cold-hearted alcoholic
and he introduced my mom to it and did a
little heroin my mom never did that
i have one brother and one sister
i want to share something with you
that's
it was private but i think i need to get
it off my chest because it's something
that you should hear and know
and it's real a dysfunctional family
will affect you
they can be dysfunctional mentally
physically
and just hurt you
and you won't know until you get older
because it's the experience that you
live as a child
i'll say
it's the experience that you live as a
child
and as you get older
if you don't experience anything else
because you've become conditioned to
your neighborhood
it's where you're comfortable at
you know
it's all you gonna know
and you
use it unconsciously
and it's the wrong thing to use
uh my name is choice mcreynolds
and uh
i just got out of prison about a year
and a half ago i spent 31 years in for
murder
and
i want to share my story with you
and i i believe that it all started with
my family
as i was growing up i never want to be
like my dad because i watched him abuse
my mom
and then when they were separated i
watched him rape my mom
and
it wasn't just once
it was about four or five times my mom
would be screaming in a room me and my
brother we're a year apart my sister's
the oldest
um
i will i would hear my mom my brother
were here
so the second time he did me and my
brother said we're going to get a gun
only thing that we could get
was a pellet gun but it looked real
enough
for us to threaten my father with
my father was an alcoholic he was a
gambler
but he handled his business
he owned two liquor stores and he worked
for the post office for 35 years and
retired
all while he was an alcoholic
the doctor told him uh
if you stop drinking you're gonna die
so he tried to stop
and he died
four years ago
um
my life began one day with this little
brother named oc
he was my partner he was a little older
than me
uh
it was just a thing where he liked me
and i liked him
he got along
he had some pcp one day
no excuse it wasn't pcp it was dust he
should call it lovely
and
he introduced me to it
i smoked it
that was the first time i ever got high
in my life i really didn't know how to
handle it
but it was a good thing that he and i
were in my garage
where no one could see him slapping the
crap out of me because i was tripping
i came out of that and i
thought i liked the high
so
that's where i started getting high at i
went from lovely to pcp and at this time
i believe i was in the sixth grade
fifth or sixth grade going to enterprise
junior high school
and
my whole neighborhood was bloods you
should call them treetops
and at some point which i don't remember
they changed from tree top to track new
and uh
i was one of the first guys to
represent dragno
by beating a guy with a baseball bat
i think back on it
i care and i don't care
because he was a guy that was doing
things
to women in the neighborhood that
shouldn't have went down
so
i begin my life of crime
uh
burglarizing
robbing stealing stealing from my family
all while i'm on pcp
i end up
smoking a lot of weed
in 1981
i was introduced to cocaine through my
sister
and my sister she would sell her body
do anything you know
i guess my sister is kind of like me but
she's a female
that started my life of just uh
knowing how to feel good
on drugs because i never felt good
being myself
uh
i really hope you can understand
and relate to what i'm saying
or
feel what i'm saying because
i was lost
i was turned out
i mean turned out
by people that i thought were my friends
in 1983
we changed our park
a city park which name is tragnu
we changed it to a black park
and we started claiming
tragnu which were crips
and uh
i began to fight more
i fought several people
and i learned how to fight
i uh
was a golden gloves title
champion
i could have went to the 84 olympics
i was born and raised in compton
start fighting for a
boxing club on broadway
and i was pretty good
it was like the only thing i was really
really good at because i was
a slow learner
because i got no help at home and by not
getting any help at home that told me
that my mom didn't really care
so back to the pellet gun me and my
brother go get a gun
and we tried to get a real gun but we
only got a pellet gun so when my dad
came back over there
he started harassing my mom
and
me and my brother opened the door he had
my mom in a choke hole
bent over on the bed
and
we pulled the gun on him he jumped off
of her
and tried to go to the window my brother
said if you go out i'm gonna shoot you
right in the head he didn't have no idea
it was a pellet gun
but it was enough to scare him not to
come to our house anymore
and do that to my mom
i ain't jumping through the story of um
being real as i can be and honest
some things you'll hear you won't like
but it's okay because it's my life
and i'll tell you who i am now at the
end
my mom ended up messing with this guy
named walter
and walter was a stone cold alcoholic
worser than my mom
hard knicker whiskey
[Music]
he ends up flipping my mom to drink
harder and more and she no longer cared
about us she didn't care if we had
clothes shoes or even if we went to
school
and as children we didn't know any
better
we accepted what it was so we start
staying outside as late as we want
fixing our own food
you know the food kind of food a kid
fixes that as a child it's junk food if
you don't burn it
or i end up uh
being one of the head guys
for tracking part
i did some things that i regret
as far as hurting other people
yeah
and i regret it i really do
um
i hurt people and in a way that
it's kind of like torture
around that time this was going on 1983.
um
i started using cocaine i smoked
primos
and i didn't really know how to handle
the addiction i thought i did
but as a stupid kid immature don't know
[ __ ]
i couldn't
i started robbing i started stealing
from my family my grandparents
and my grandparents were the
stone to my family they were the chief
when my grandparents said it it was done
whenever my grandmother said she wanted
to go wherever it was done
so
when she passed away my family passed
away too because they all separated
and
my mom like i said was an alcoholic
and she was an alcoholic in my life for
at least 15 years
or more
i never lost respect for my mom
even to this day
i tell my mom you did what you had to do
because i'm here now
but my
attitude
towards life
is like what she had when she was
drinking
don't care just give up but don't hurt
anybody
you know work for what you want pay for
what you want no matter if it's drugs
or an office job just pay for what you
want
that's where my life is right now
going back to 83
i started smoking primos my sister
introduced me to it
i start robbing i start stealing
and i end up going to the youtube door
not to use authority i never went to uh
los petrino's
first juvenile facility i went to when i
was about 15 you know about 14 years old
1 or 15. actually i take that back i was
15 going on 16 because my son was born
when i was 16.
he's 42
right now
he'll be 43 next year and he rest in
peace i'll share that with you
i started stealing robin and gang man
i thought drive-bys was the thing of the
thing to do
we wanted to take over a neighborhood
we're gonna go take it over shoot some
guys up
it wasn't any initiation it was just
something fun to do because we're stupid
again it goes back to my family
not caring not raising i was a kid that
stayed out all night long if i wanted to
if i wanted to go to school i'd go to
school
at one time in my life my mother
put me on the yellow bus
for slow people because i was a slow
learner
and um
me and my brother took that same pellet
gun the second day he came and went up
to the driver's window and told him if
you ever come here again or put a bullet
in your head so he never came back my
mom never knew
the guy she was with walter
he used to get robbed he was an
lax airline mechanic
made good money
and i used to rob him before he went to
my house because he would cast his check
up at nick's cash and check cash in
place and i'd wait for him in the alley
i knew that was guaranteed money walter
was a scary guy
but when he get drunk he was a mean guy
to a woman
but he was a punk to a man
uh
so i robbed him about three times
and uh
i didn't feel anything about it because
i didn't think she treated my mom the
way she should have been treated but he
was nice to her he gave her what she
wanted
alcohol money
seduction
i ended up doing a burglary
on a liquor store
and
coincidentally the only thing i took out
the liquor store was liquor
i didn't even grab the money in a
register i just took liquor
so i went back home
and i gave my mom a yelling at johnny
walker red
big gallon
because as long as she's drunk she ain't
worried about us i realized that
and she said if you're going to get high
you make your little clubhouse in the
garage
and smoke do what you want to do why
would a mom say do what you want to do
because she's not being a parent and
don't know any better
so
i end up on this burglary going to los
petrinos
where
it wasn't that bad because i got the
chance to shower every day
i had brand new shoes i got clothes even
though the gel clothes i got
them uh
i ended up going from los patrinos
to the youth authority six months no
three months after i got out of la
petrinos i spent six months in i got out
three months later i go to the youth
authority i go to the youth authority
as a juvenile
and i stayed in the youth authority for
four years
they had a boxing team there and i got
on it and i shined i boxed real good
and
the 84 olympics i could have went to
but
my stupidity
my addiction
and no
support
i did what i could know best
what made me comfortable i went back to
doing them
so
i ended up going to uh the youth
authority
i did five years in yts
my y number is 30538
and this is up to the year 1986.
and i believe i'm
16 going on 17 years old
no i'll take that back i'm 19 years old
and i'm introduced to prison one of the
first prisons i hit was avanallah state
prison
and as the guys in prison say it's
rocking and rolling up there
so i grew up in prison
and
i'm an active gang member
a general in my neighborhood
i uh
start buffing iron
i'm getting big
i swell up to about a 19 and a half i'm
squatting 650
i'm looking like a real gorilla
to the other guys in prison
and this ain't no lie what i'm telling
you you can check it all with my c uh y
um
[Music]
so this guy was talking to me one day
and i knew in order to survive in prison
you act crazy
you know you act like uh
you really care but you don't care i'm
gonna beat you down if you don't do this
the way i want you to do it
if i tell you to take two matches out
the book and you take three i'm gonna
stab you
that was the attitude you had to have in
prison back then
or
you would get stabbed
so one day we had to meet everybody from
compton
and
the guys on the yard surprised me they
say man you're the most maturest of us
and uh you need to run the car
i guess i got that maturity from uh
lost petrinos
so
i uh start dictating what's going on
this and that
and
that actually conditions your mind
to go on because you're profiting from
it so you don't see no wrong in it
[ __ ] i tell this dude man look you need
to get 15 worth of store you get 15. and
they're dropping it off at your bed
you think i'm gonna tell them to stop
you do you think you're gonna see
something wrong in that remember i had
no home training
i i didn't really have no schooling i
was a guy that couldn't read and i was
in junior high school
i couldn't comprehend i couldn't spell
and i didn't know math
i knew i knew
how to get to a hundred i know how to
count money by sight
but if you put it on paper i have a
problem with it
and i i was dyslexic and slow
as a learner
so
i uh
end up running the car
and i went to prison in 86 i got out in
88
i stayed out 31 days and went back the
first time i went i had three years
second time i went back i had four years
third time i went back i did eight years
fourth time i went back i did close to
nine years
the fifth time i went back this is all
cdc under the cdc number of d62281
uh
i went back
and
this was around i think my fifth or
sixth trip to prison
and i was going back
because i didn't care i knew i could do
the time and i knew i'm gonna be looked
out for in there
it's just how it is
so
i go back to prison
for the sixth time
somewhere in the 90s i don't remember
in uh
just a little later than that
i believe
i did 14 years when i went back i don't
remember the year or anything
and uh i get out
i've done a total
of
maybe 36
38 years in prison
and i'm
59 58 years old you do the math on how
long i've been on the street
um
i told a gentleman that's during the
interview
that i just spent 31 years in prison
but i did do 31 but not consecutive the
most time i did consecutive was 16
14 and 16 back to back
i got out shot a guy
you know
so here i am now
after all that time i've been out 18
months
struggling living on spirit road
still thinking i'm the enforcer that
kid's mine
the child life
each time i went to prison it was for a
robbery strong robbery robbery with a
weapon and a murder
um
i've even been convicted
of a rape
that wasn't even a rape you know me and
this girl was
24
or 25
matter of fact she was 29 because i had
the paperwork and i was 16.
and i got convicted uh i was 15 and i
got convicted
of raping her
and
as the years turned
the conviction was overturned
by uh the fbi or someone
because i was a juvenile and she was the
adult
and trying to extort my mom
because she was a drunk
[Music]
i've been out about 18 months
the
parole
will talk to you as if you're a kid they
talk at you
you have to go in there and kiss their
ass in order to get something done
the things that they tell you in prison
that are waiting for you when you get
out here
is not here
i've been out 18 months and i've beat
about
17 people up i've stabbed two people
and i was gonna murder someone else
when i was in prison all those times
my
homies in prison that were older than me
shared something with me that they told
me man you're a dummy
you're a dumbass you know
not saying
how you
have your structure amongst your people
but literally literally
you can't read a book or something so
i happened to be
i was in folsom
prison
and my celli
was a muslim brother
and he influenced me to learn
so i began learning right there and
i learned some things about myself that
i liked and didn't like
long story short
i'm
uh able to read able to comprehend and i
read at an excellent level i bet people
down on spirit role right now today they
can't beat me in math
you can't beat me in spelling and i can
name the last 30 super bowls in a row
team for team if you can do it i give
you a thousand dollars out of my pocket
nobody has won yet
that's a fact
i educated myself
in
psychology
uh
i like to talk
i didn't really get deep into my story
because
it hurts me to know that that was me
you know i have a son
had a son
he's 42 right now he'll be 43
july 1st
uh
i always
told myself
that i'd never be like my dad
i've never hit a woman
because of the abuse
that my dad
did to my mom
i ended up
being like my father because
i only held my son
when he was a baby
i'm afraid
to fight to fight it
because i'm addicted to
i'm
drugs
i live on skid row
i never even
i never even owned a suit in my life
i never bought a car
for anything
it's like i'm an adult that can only
function in prison
that's why it's easy for me to commit a
crime to go back
i told myself
i won't commit a felony
but i never told myself i won't go back
my son died
and
i never do it
i talked to my son one day
and this is for every man
i talked to my son
in a conversation he said okay dad i got
it
[Music]
so
i changed my life
because
i don't want to be
incarcerated number one
i am running on probation
because they put you in places where
they infested with bedbugs and groceries
and stuff
i was gonna stay here
some people say
i'd rather be
in a halfway house or somewhere
within prisons
i want people with their black bed bugs
and big roaches i mean all bad
oh
but the probation in parole is panties
people
absolutely i do
i'm a certified welder
i do ac air conditioning
i don't even have the strength to go
with a job because my feet hurt
it hurt from walking
having to defend yourself
i know a lot of people down here a lot
i gave my life to christ
it feels like
i'm just singing
my mom is good
even though my mother
was an alcoholic
my mom never gave up on me i went to
prison she's always looked out for me
send me whatever i need
her sisters tell her that's an enabler
she said that's my [ __ ] baby i'm
always looking for
i can't even see my [ __ ]
so you never know man what's going on in
another man's heart
you never know
that's why you should be kind to
everybody
if you did the math on my time
i've only been out of prison as an adult
maybe
20 months or something
so i'm slow
but i'm an addict
a smoke crack
i smoke crack to this day
i tell myself i probably only live about
35 more years
do i want a life do i want a job
and uh
ah
[Music]
it's hard to do it
i lost my ids
my social security card
three months ago and i never went to get
another one
yeah
it's like i'm an adult man
but i make
childish decisions
because i need someone to hold me
and that's sad
but grown people need it
so
you got to be aware of what's going on
in your life
i don't ever want to go back to prison
even though i can go to prison and i
go to pia get a job
i elevate
i haven't been
i don't stay stagnated in one place
i need man jobs
when i get out here
i get lost
mentally
and i do cocaine i smoke cry
and
i like to
get a girl and have fun
smoking dope
sexual stuff
and
that's an addiction in itself
it's like
your penis don't even rise unless you're
doing that
because i've conditioned myself and my
mind to that
i've never shared this with no one
when you grow up in the system
you become a sister
i treat people the way the guards
treated me
some good some bad
i try to stay
as clean as i can
roomed up so when someone looks at me
they'll say oh he's not homeless you
know he might be on some dope
it's all the facade
continuing to pool myself
that what i'm doing is okay
but i think it is
i have no will to go anywhere
i have no one in my life to care about
to give it that i probably don't even
care about myself
everything that i've ever had in life
was given to me
i think i bought a pair of shoes and a
shirt a couple of times in my life
there was some blue khakis and a blue
shirt
because
the gang said we're gonna have a picnic
other than that
i've been wearing jail [ __ ] all my life
yts
lost petrinos
central juvenile hall
camp muns camp rocky kilpatrick
to hatch
folsom pelican bay color pack
i have been all these places
pelican bay was somewhere
where they put you
where you can't dictate to nobody
but after a couple of guards got stabbed
there
the cops eased up
and the politics began in prison
that's some of my story right now
[Music]
i get very emotional when i think about
my son
he's married his four kids
and
i know he wasn't
a terrific guy i held him in my hands he
was maybe a year old
but
all my life
in prison i wanted to be a father
so i try and reach out and contact them
but once i got out of prison i ain't
give a [ __ ]
why that is i don't know
because i got out chasing the dope again
[Music]
didn't really deal with my addiction
i'd been through sap programs
i became mentors in each program
i was offering an otc counseling course
completed it
i had three and a half years of college
coastline community college
and
like i said i'm a certified welder
i stole it all away
for my own feelings
um
i thank you for listening and uh
if you ever want to know something
ask me
the only thing in life
i believe
is permanent
it's change
and death
nothing else
thank you
thank you
you